I mean the the Julie Cameron artist way
you know so that idea of morning Pages
didn't just write don't judge just
whatever comes out it doesn't matter
which was also David milch exercise
where he said to get your creative
juices going for two weeks right for 20
minutes a day
print it and then tear it up
just to get used to your brain being
creative but he said you'll open up you
know that part of your brain and it'll
fire up and then it builds itself to be
creative yeah if you just start doing it
there's something about consistency and
momentum also yeah build a little
momentum and then you're kind of then
suddenly there's something real about it
and then you're like oh this is a real
thing yeah and I always think if I'm on
page 60 I can finish finish it in a
weekend I could write 20 Pages a day for
two days and have a really shitty draft
and then I'll fix it up